I have an announcement to make everyone
have real line scripts of timeless the
Christmas movie part 1 and part 2 just
for you from the cast so kind and I kind
of just hugged your arm that I'm sorry I
didn't want to lose that oh my gosh
thank you Mike thank you you
single-handedly saved our show I did not
but I do love that they listened a
little bit because here's the thing it
is such a great show I mean do you feel
like you can teach history at this point
yes okay so everyone gather round not at
all I actually just have a really good
memory and I was kind of beautiful
minding all of those historical tales
and from the show but I get stopped all
the time when I travel from history
professors and teachers like oh my gosh
I share timeless with my students and
they think that I know things and I'm
like you don't want to ask me about that
but I could give you a mano but I will
say that's one of the reasons why I
really love the show I thought it was so
cool out tied in historical events and
how it just was kind of a really
innovative show nothing had been done
like that thanks it was in a different
movie every week and you have you about
12 year old right yeah he 13 now 13 yeah
my son is 11 and it was great to just a
show that I could do that he could watch
absolutely I will not stop talking until
you subscribe to my youtube channel
that's right and I could talk a lot
seriously not gonna stop yep still here
not going anywhere I see you don't walk
away from this